most of us have never been in the
concentration camp experience we've
never had to go through that horror and
tragedy and so one would think that
today it would be easier to find meaning
in life and yet I sense that it's more
difficult in a sense today than it was
in years past do you do you think
they're absolutely right why is it
because we are living in a society
either in terms of an affluent society
or in terms of a welfare state as we in
Austria are living in anyway these types
of societies virtually or at least they
are out virtually to satisfy and gratify
each and every human need except for one
need the most basic and fundamental need
operandi man the need for meaning
consumer societies even creating needs
but the need for meaning or as I'm used
to referring to it
the way to meaning remains unfulfilled
it's what I'm used to is calling
recently the unheard cry for meaning you
scarcely will find any reference to what
is the most fundamental and basic
concern of man neither pleasure nor
happiness nor power prestige but
originally and basically his wish his
desire to find and fulfill a meaning in
his life or for that matter in each
single life situation confronting him
and if there is a meaning to fulfill if
he's aware if if it becomes cognizant of
such a meaning then he's ready to suffer
he is ready to offer sacrifices he is
ready to undergo tension stress and so
forth without any harm being done to his
to his health but if there is no meaning
of
eleven old meaning in in in his visual
field then he takes his life can you
imagine it's a situation for a human
being which is more full of stress than
a schvitz
and virtually all neurotic
symptomatology disappeared
in oceans and the degree to which
suicide took place in Auschwitz and
Dachau was astonishingly astonishingly
surprisingly low on the other hand in
the welfare state of Austria a teacher
showed me a list of questions his
students his pupils were allowed to ask
him and you know what was top ranking on
the list as to it the frequency of the
questions suicide among youngsters of 14
to 15 years of age in a welfare state
such as Austria suicide there were
virtually no stores or tensions because
they are pampered nobody allows himself
to challenge them what young people need
our ideals and challenges personal tasks
and and to begin with in the first place
examples personal examples but not the
cowards who coward people who don't
venture to confront them with anything
because they might become angry because
they are challenged neither parents nor
school teachers are courageous enough to
challenge them the hold arouse tensions
don't create tensions don't put stress
on them see people are today they are
not over demand that they are under
demanded